what do you think the media got wrong
about 2016 and the election outcome I
think they underestimated rural America
that we hire our own people we have our
own thoughts and a lot of times we get
grouped in it's just a bunch of farmers
who don't have any thoughts and it's
absolutely not true
Howard County Iowa we're almost half the
voters are registered as independents
and the other half are nearly split even
between Democrats and Republicans it's
the only County in the u.s. that voted
by more than 20 percentage points for
President Obama in 2012 and more than 20
percentage points for president Trump
four years later it swung 41 points the
second-largest flip in the nation we sat
down with seven Howard County voters at
the fairgrounds in the city of Cresco to
get their take on why the county swung
so drastically and gain an understanding
of what's going to be important to them
in the 2020 election maybe if we could
just do a show of hands who voted for
Barack Obama in 2012 who voted for
Donald Trump in 2016
Barry you're of a true Obama Trump voter
why did you vote the way you did those
two different election cycles what
relates the most to me and it's not red
or blue Republican or Democrat or any
other who do I think is the best choice
for not only what's helping me grow on
on my business or my farm but who's the
best current leader for our country in
2012 I felt things were doing really
good we had a good thing going in the
agriculture community so there wasn't
anything wrong with John McCain it was
just keeping the status quo when it came
to 2016
I felt like Donald Trump had more
similar interests to what we did I know
maybe it was a lesser of two evils right
I felt like he had the the best outlook
for the AG community in general neil has
Republican chairman who do you see in
the Democratic field who would have the
best chance of beating Donald Trump in a
County like Howard honestly a Midwestern
or amy klobuchar and I don't understand
why she isn't doing
better in Iowa I prefer to see some
younger people on on the board so that's
I attended a peat booted edge rally and
it was it was wonderful Trump wasn't
your first pick for a Republican nominee
in 2016 are you on the fence at all
might you vote for a Democrat it would
take a lot to do that I think it's just
speaks to the people in the community
that we're that open-minded or that
secure and our own self beliefs that you
can go to a pee booted edge can rally or
Bernie Sanders rally and and pick up on
the things that they the good things
that they're talking about and maybe
sway your own political party to do the
same I've always said there's no one
person is going to find someone that
agrees with them a hundred percent I'm
always on at 60/40
I might believe with one party 60% of
the time and can't stand 40 percent of
what they're saying and you should never
be afraid of listening to the other side
for the good things that they're talking
about show of hands how many of you
agree with Neal's 6040 rule most of you
you don't feel like you have to be a
hundred percent with a particular party
at any given time yep if we build a wall
and I throw my rocks over at Neal and he
throws his rocks over at me what are we
gonna solve other than exchanging rocks
we have to communicate Laurie or the
Democratic party chair but you also work
in the healthcare sector what would you
like to see done with the healthcare
issue well there's definitely a huge
problem and I think when these
candidates talk about Medicare for all
like that I don't see that being a
reality I understand I work at the
hospital here to this hospital sometimes
doesn't get paid for 90 120 days from
Medicaid we're a tiny rural Hospital we
can't afford that who in the Democratic
field has a plan that you think is
viable
I like Pete Buddha judge most people
here know that because he's gives you an
option I think that you've got you can
have Medicare for all if you want it but
if your unions giving you a great deal
on your insurance you don't want to get
rid of it you can keep it and I think
that sounds to most people a little less
scary than just saying we're gonna do
Medicare for all we all know there's a
problem why can't we all sit down on the
table Neal and I could sit down at the
table I feel like and work it out all
right Neal she set you up what what what
how do you fix health care so when the
Affordable Health Care Act was passed
President Obama said you can keep your
health plan if you like and after that
happened you know there were some things
that made that more difficult mainly and
one of the main reasons that Trump did
so wellness County is that farmers have
to self-insure unless they have a spouse
or they have a job in town that provides
their insurance we were pieing our own
and the plans that we had pretty much
became outlawed or made it very
difficult and the costs so they may not
just taken him away or said you can't
have them but cost skyrocketed after the
mayor fordable Care Act went into place
so even though you could still keep your
your plan you couldn't afford to you
could just raise your hands if you're
satisfied with the way the economy is
going right now okay so about half of
you are for those of you who aren't
satisfied why are you not satisfied with
the economy right now because people
aren't spending and you're a small
business owner yet are you feeling the
slowdown yes and especially over the
Christmas time is usually the best time
for retailers for small businesses
including Small Business Saturday is
usually the biggest day that we have and
this year was no comparison for the last
two years
raus year in the waste collection
business I guess there's always gonna be
demand for that because we're always
everybody even if the economy is good or
bad you're gonna make some garbage how
are you feeling about the economy well
most of the time I think we're kind of
for lack of a better word a little
bellwether on how the economy is we know
when people are cutting back because
when you're when you're cutting back you
aren't throwing things out you're not
building as much this is the slowest
that we've been in
her with some sections of our business
in years so you're detecting a slowdown
potentially that definitely definitely
and I go yeah go ahead I'd have to
disagree with that as far as my business
conservation so what we do is we help
farmers find incentives and grants to
pay for projects the farmer has to pay a
certain percentage of that this last
year we had our biggest year as far as
conservation Kenny you work at a
manufacturing company here in Howard
County you didn't raise your hand when I
asked about how whether you feel
positive about the economy or not
how have shifts been are you able to get
as much work as you want how is the
Union feeling about things right now
we're just worried about our future I
mean we had a peak of about 450
employees and now we're down to less
than 300 the workforce keeps getting
smaller and the production that takes a
lot of manpower a lot of labor input are
the ones that are leaving the high
profit production with low employee
input are the ones that are staying here
this panel has dramatically more
diversity on it than the county does if
you could I would just like you to talk
a little bit about what it is like to be
a person of color in this county I've
only lived here for five years I have
never felt so black in my life living
here the racism I have not personally
felt it or dealt with it
I mean I've noticed things when people
don't know me but I feel like everybody
knows me now so I don't feel that
anymore but my 14 year old with her
peers I mean she's calling her like five
six seven eight nine ten times since
third grade now she's in eighth grade
Ross how long have you lived in the
county and sort of what's your
experience about it I've been probably
here in the neighborhood of 30 years I
think it's a it's a situation of the
times I think
younger children they're experiencing
problems that we never did before
it's openly racist to to a lot of young
kids we don't see that though it's it's
it's like we're going backwards yeah do
you attribute any of this to the tone
the president uses sometimes definitely
definitely Neil as the Republican
chairman can you just respond a little
bit to the the tone of the president
what's your take on that well obviously
the president's rhetoric on a lot of
issues and individuals a particularly if
it's a political opponent he usually
goes to a more of a personal attack on
someone and but that's part of his
personality and that's being the
outsider that he he promised to be he's
definitely not a politician
just his approach to draining the swamp
and things like that that that's very
appealing to people but the tone and the
rhetoric definitely is not something
that any of us appreciate our or condone
you guys are equally divided both
Republicans Democrats and independents
roughly who thinks the wall is a good
idea who likes to what the president is
doing with the wall how does the
immigration issue play here in the
county I don't have a whole lot of
experience with that but I know working
in agricultural industry being
surrounded I mean we struggle to get
workers that are willing to work around
here right now
a lot of a lot of farms depend on those
agricultural visas the immigrants that
are coming here came here for the same
reason that most of our ancestors did to
better themselves and if I'd work and
find work I think immigration is really
needed in the country but we need it to
be done legally through a process not
just eagle Ely just walking across the
border and making sure you contribute to
the society problem with that is is it's
not being done quick enough there are
plenty of farmers in this area that have
immigrants working I would say most of
them are not necessarily concerned about
whether their leave
or not the farmers that I know have
tried to get help locally and they were
unable to get it one way a person can
measure the quality of life in a country
is if people are dying to get into the
country or dying to leave and we have
people dying to get into this country
Barry how are you feeling about the farm
economy it's had ups and downs obviously
over the last few years there's been
years that have been good there's been
years that have been bad so over the
last couple of years it feels like
treading water president Trump's trade
war has obviously affected agriculture
how are you feeling about the trade
situation right now it looks a lot
better now than it did even a few months
ago but obviously as we've lost trade
partners our overabundance of supply
kind of combination of both things have
made the farm economy weaker as we lose
trade partners and keep producing more
than we ever had before
Courtney how are you feeling about the
farm economy in your own family farm
well for my husband and I personally I
mean we're a small farm so it may not be
large dips and like Larten it's big dips
and small rises but as being a small and
young farmers we were just starting we
definitely feel those a lot more than a
more diversified larger farm does so I
mean we obviously have to supplement our
farm with all farm income are you
supportive of this trade fight the
president is leading yes hopefully
long-term gains we might struggle a
little bit short term just because again
we're small we're just starting but long
term hopefully its positives the
caucuses are are mostly for Democrats
this time who intends to go to the
Democratic caucuses okay four of you and
who are you each leaning towards go
ahead I believe and Lizabeth it this
time possibly Pete Pete you've endorsed
Pete most likely Pete Bernie so we have
one maybe Warren won maybe Pete won
maybe Bernie you guys pretty much cover
the whole spread there's no bite there's
no Biden supporters in the crowd well
that's Howard Coney
[Laughter]
[Music]